here's the good news YouTube is healthy
growing and the most profitable channel
to establish your brand but short form
video is coming for the throne sixty
percent of all videos published on the
internet in 2020 were under two minutes
long so here's the bad news those who
ignore short form video will suffer the
consequences
welcome to the think media podcast my
name is Heather Torres the host of this
show where we want to help you grow your
influence on YouTube and then turn that
influence into a high income and a high
impact online business and if you're
brand new to the show and today's your
first episode we want to welcome you to
the think media fam every single Tuesday
we release a brand new episode so make
sure you're locked in and subscribed
wherever you like to listen to your
content on now today is exciting because
we're going to be jumping into a
two-part series we're kind of pulling
back the curtain to one of the keynote
sessions at our conference grow with
video live now this conference was sold
out and this content you're getting
today is not released anywhere else so
make sure you're locked in here for this
episode and The Following episode so you
can get all of this keynote now today
we're walking through a keynote from our
founder and CEO of think media Sean
Cannell he's the best-selling author of
the book YouTube Secrets he's my co-host
here on the think media show and this
keynote I would say is one of the best
he's delivered in this episode we're
going to walk through some of the big
social media trends that you need to be
aware of and as we know there are
challenges for Content creators but in
this episode we're going to be sharing
with you when you know the right tools
and the right strategies how you can be
winning online so stay locked here with
your pen your notepad if you're driving
turn the volume up because you need to
listen and let's get into our first part
of this session
foreign
we're going to talk about the four
business and marketing trends that you
need to know this is like the online
video State of the Union we're going to
talk about the huge opportunity and
major challenges that you must overcome
right now we're going to talk about how
to kill overwhelm and create profitable
content in less time and we're going to
talk about how to eliminate time wasters
and get laser focused on the right
things that actually grow your business
and generate cash
and so let's dive into these four
business and marketing Trends you know A
lot's happened in the last couple years
this is some new data and some new stats
and I have four of them and the first
one is this video is King it's good news
that you're at growing video video is
king and you know this is confirmed this
is what Forbes said in 2022 video is
where we all need to be look at the
person next to you and say you're right
where you need to be
is what Forbes said this is true listen
to this
in 2022 82 of global internet traffic
will come from video streaming and
downloads video is King
now this this stat right here 500 hours
of video content is being uploaded to
YouTube Every Minute in 2022.
and here's the thing as we go through
these trends
I actually have we're going to be
identifying some good news
we're also going to be talking about
some bad news because I hope you get
hyped at this conference you know I hope
that you know oh we're gonna get on an
emotional high it's a conference cool
and I actually love that I I I'm ready
to dance and party with the best of them
but I actually want to give you solid
substance and I need you to we need to
face reality that's what leaders do they
face reality but with unshakable
optimism
and so we're going to talk about some of
the good news and the bad news and 500
hours of video content being uploaded to
YouTube Every Minute Of 2022 is actually
kind of bad news
all right this is the truth competition
continues to increase
and I know you feel it it's a 2022 World
it's harder to stand out than it ever
has been before but here's the good news
the demand for good content is
skyrocketing let me prove it to you the
average hours of online video watch per
week if you're watching online look at
the screen if you're in the room look at
the screen notice how since 2020 uh 2018
to 2022 every year it goes up and this
is an average across across all humans
that every year more people are watching
more content so even though there's more
competition there's more demand
and listen to this the demand for video
content is increasing 54 of consumers
want to see more video content from a
brand or a business that they support
and so people want you to be creating
video but here's the second trend
YouTube is ruling the kingdom
yeah yeah
2.3 billion monthly active users are on
YouTube right now and YouTube is Still
The King Of The Hill in the video World
however here's the big three and here's
the data number one it's YouTube number
two it's Instagram and number three it's
tick tock four the share of digital
video consumption and so you can look
Snapchat is still a major player for the
younger generation and Facebook is still
in the game a little bit uh but YouTube
is definitely the leader here's the good
news YouTube is healthy growing and the
most profitable channel to establish
your brand
but
Trend number three
short form video is coming for the
throne
and there's some competitors that are
pretty close to YouTube right now
sixty percent of all videos published on
the internet in 2020 were under two
minutes long who here is creating short
form content waving me raise your hand
awesome awesome
yeah and and Tick Tock users now spend
more time on Tick Tock than on Instagram
and Facebook
it's it's something around 36 minutes a
day Facebook video consumption is like
32 minutes and so Tick Tock has just
been exploding in fact 40 percent of gen
Z spends more than three hours a day on
tick tock
wow parents are like Oh shoot that's
what my kids are doing
that's three hours a day dude that's
like a long time that's a lot of tick
tock especially anybody any Tick Tock
Watchers here especially like you're in
that feed they're 10 seconds each like
you're just droning on just tick tock
tick tock that's what's happening man
and uh this is what's this is this is
big news that Tick Tock just announced
Tick Tock is exploring their first
program of sharing ad money with some
creators
and they're actually going to be paying
50 of the money generated from some
advertising right now to top creators
and creators that have over a hundred
thousand followers but this just shows
us that Tick Tock is gunning for YouTube
everybody this is Game of Thrones man
everyone's fighting to be king of the
hill do I think that YouTube is
threatened no but I think it's important
that we pay attention to what is
happening on this platform and these
other platforms and here's the key stat
the percentage of young us digital video
viewers who watch video on Instagram and
Tick Tock is within shouting distance of
YouTube so here's the bad news
those who ignore short form video will
suffer the consequences
it's true listen I'm still all for long
form I think long form is where the
impact is and we're going to be
exploring all of these at this event but
we have to be embracing short form in
fact the good news is those who Embrace
short form video will multiply their
impact here's what we've been doing at
think media you know uh some people call
me a boomer I'm actually a millennial
but as my beard started to get a little
bit gray you know I don't know if you
ever read your you know comments you
should probably avoid your comments just
on the internet they're kind of a
dumpster fire right you get somebody
telling me just like they're just like
dude why why is why do you have the face
of a boy but the beard of an old man
literally these are it's every day you
know thanks I really needed to wake up
hearing that right and so I'll be honest
with you you know I I now have been
doing this it's crazy I've been doing
video for over 20 years I started from
my local church in 2003. and so it could
be easy to get set in our ways and I
want to talk to us if you've been doing
it a certain way you know it's like oh
yeah YouTube's my jam or whatever's my
jam Facebook it's my jam and it's all
cool but sometimes I'm to the place
where I'm like man I gotta learn a new
thing
man I gotta start a new platform really
really you know and I never thought I'd
be that guy you know but now I'm kind of
like I'm just like I know YouTube like
do I want to do this Tick Tock thing and
so thank God that Steph desevo uh joined
the think media team he's one of our
editors he's all into you know nfts in
fact Gary's gonna be here tomorrow night
Steph just got back from vcon and uh and
he started to tick tock he didn't even
tell me
like just unsanctioned activity
happening at think media it's total it's
Anarchy here like I mean it looks like
we have it all together when you know
maybe from the Internet it's crazy uh
and so he just starts The Tick Tock I
don't even know the login to our own
Tick Tock right
and literally from just repurposing
check it out repurposing our long form
videos into short form videos in a few
short months we've grown to over 41 000
followers in tick tock like just organic
Greeks now you could do this a lot
better after lunch we're going to be
learning better strategies than this but
but here's kind of the lesson I want to
encourage you whether you kind of feel
like you're ready to learn new things or
you feel kind of settled we got to be
open to new possibilities we got to be
open to Reinventing ourselves we got to
be open to adapting our strategies and I
know that's why you're here but but
short form gives us a major opportunity
we started posting some of these same
repurpose videos on my Instagram reels
and they're getting between two to fifty
thousand views but here's the really
cool thing
YouTube shorts
YouTube shorts uh a lot of us probably
know about it but it's a brand new right
offering that YouTube is has put out
there to compete with other short form
platforms like Tick Tock and Instagram
and the fact that you could also do
Facebook reels and linkedin's adding
reels and my Beard's getting grayer as I
think about every platform you need to
but but YouTube shorts we see 15 billion
views daily so here's all we do we
actually make vertical videos and we
spread them across YouTube shorts Tick
Tock and Instagram we'll use them in
multiple places in fact one of the
biggest strategies we're going to be
talking about is how you can work
smarter and not just harder
how you can have a better system and
have processes to help you ultimately
distribute your content with less stress
and less overwhelm but this brings us to
Trend number four Trend number four and
it's this the digital Gold Rush is here
the digital Gold Rush is here
signal fire uh released a report on the
Creator economy and they discovered this
being a content creator is actually the
fastest growing type of small business
that's crazy I remember growing I grew
up in a small town I grew up in
Marysville uh Washington Arlington
Washington an hour north of Seattle and
uh I remember I would go to Subway
anybody love Subway come on give me one
of those meatball subs come on just
packed with it's not even real meatballs
you know it's packed with sugar you know
just the bread okay you know you know
you can open like a Subway franchise
it's like a type of small business you
could say you could start a franchise
and think about that maybe you go get a
small business loan right you go down to
the bank maybe you open a coffee shop if
you come from the Northwest you probably
like coffee
Starbucks we got coffee espresso stands
on every corner and my in fact I met my
beautiful wife Sonia she's a Starbucks
barista
yeah yeah and and so you could think
about you open up a coffee shop you
maybe have to lease some space buy some
signage hire a team you have to you know
get some the register get the coffee and
the average small business right is not
profitable for 16 to 24 or even 36
months this is what it means to be an
entrepreneur and start a business well
we are living in an era now where you
could start a business from home as a
Creator where you could start an online
business and this is now a fact that
starting a creator-based business is the
fastest growing type of small business
influencer marketing Hub revealed that 2
million Global content creators make six
figures right now 2 million and Forbes
predicts this and this is good news that
you came to grow a video live or that
you're joining us online is is this
report that they wrote about the crater
economy that over the next
seven months in 2022 they predict that
there's going to be 5x growth in the
market size of the crater economy over
the next six months so where you're
sitting right now is absolutely
incredible because if you get this
information and you take action on this
like there's a wave coming this isn't
hype right now the crater economy is
valued at two billion dollars with
estimations that it could grow to over
104 billion dollars by the end of the
year man it's time to get positioned man
it's time to get focused man it's time
to get your game right your strategy on
come on your mind right your mindset
right your content strategy dialed in 5x
growth you're not going to get 5x growth
in the stock market right now you just
got 5x loss in your Bitcoin account
come on it's time to lean into the
crater economy right
but here's here's one of the facts that
was kind of startling
two million people 200 million people
are actually earning money from digital
content creation
200 million have earned money the
internet has sent them money via wire
transfer check in the mail or connecting
their AdSense account in whatever way
you're getting your money from Amazon
Associates or your e-commerce stripe
account like whatever
200 million but here's the bad news 68
of part-time creators earn less than one
thousand dollars
but here's the good news
with the right skill strategies and
business model you can thrive
and if you've earned one dollar online
even if you haven't earned a dollar yet
the good news especially though if
you've earned a dollar is we can turn
that into 10 and then we could turn that
into a thousand and then we could turn
that into a thousand a month and ten
thousand a month and whatever goal
because with the right skills that
you're going to learn the strategies and
business model you can Thrive
well I hope that you got value out of
the first part of this session and in
the next episode we're going to be
diving into even more we're going to be
giving you two questions that Sean asks
that are going to really help unlock the
next phase of your YouTube Journey now
if you didn't hear you can go to
21videotips.com that's your next move if
you want to get more information on
video marketing just like this we had
some incredible speakers like Patrick
Bet David and Alex hermosi sharing some
of their most valuable tips that they've
not shared anywhere else and you can get
all that and more inside of the
21videotips.com so go there right now to
get your free downloadable resource and
that entire free master class now every
single week we love to shout out someone
from our think media community and
normally we read your reviews that you
leave over on Apple iTunes but did you
know that our podcast is actually
featured over on YouTube as well we
release a brand new episode every single
Tuesday but we have exclusive content
that's only available over on the
YouTube channel so if you've not been
there yet I want to encourage you to go
there also today comes from ukulele Zen
a comment left on a recent episode with
Omar altakori and Nolan malt from the
think media team and he said this is a
great episode Omar and Nolan would be
wonderful to have again thanks for all
you're doing to help content creators
around the world well ukulele Zen thank
you for leaving that comment and thank
you for letting us know that you liked
that format with other content creators
here on the podcast and uh I assume that
Omar and Nolan will come back at some
point here on the show thank you so much
for being a part of what we're doing
here at think media we're so encouraged
by reading your comments on the YouTube
channel and your reviews over on Apple
podcast it means the world to me that
you would take just a moment out of your
day to let us know that this free
content is helping you thanks so much
for listening and make sure you tune in
for the next episode so you can get the
second half of this amazing keynote
we'll see you soon
[Music]